By randomly assigning groups, the different groups on average will be similar
to each other. They will have about the same number of men and women, young and
old, and all different characteristics. With random assignment, we can say that
the two groups were equivalent at the start of the study. That way, any changes
at the end of the study are most likely due to our independent variable,
caffeine. Random assignment helps to eliminate bias. There was a good reason
why we didn't want to use the other types of groups, such as male and female.
Or the first half of the participants who showed up got caffeine, and the
second half didn't get caffeine. There's something innately different between
those two groups. And by using random assignment, we don't have to worry about
that.